today on the matt walsh show officials
in dc are finally
after four months telling us the truth
about the alleged deadly riot at the
capitol on january 6
and the truth is the opposite of what
we've been told this whole entire time
also five headlines including
mainstream media journalists and legal
analysts prove that they don't
understand how our court systems work in
this country at all they don't even
understand it on a fundamental level
the the judge in the showing case also
admonishes maxine waters
planned parenthood faces up to its
racist past sort of
and incest advocates make their case for
marriage equality
why why shouldn't we tolerate and accept
their alternative lifestyle we'll talk
about that and much more today on the
matt walsh show
now it's time to check in with policy
genius policy genius can help you
compare top insurers in one place and
say 50
or more on life insurance you know it's
uh it's it used to be very hard to
before policy genius if you wanted to
get affordable life insurance
it was difficult to know where to look
what's a good deal what isn't you got to
go through all the red tape
well positive genius has taken that
complication away once you find your
best option on policy genius the palsy
genius team
will set up your new policy for you and
answer any questions you have along the
way
and you can feel good knowing that your
family has financial protection
getting started is easy okay first head
to policygenius.com
three minutes you can work out how much
coverage you need you can compare quotes
to find your best price since their
license agents work for you
not the insurance companies there's zero
hassle if you hit any speed bumps along
the way
policy news will take care of everything
you know you could trust them
that kind of service has earned policy
genius a five-star rating across
thousands of reviews on google and trust
pilot best part
all the benefits of policy genius um the
comparison tool the handling of
paperwork the unbiased device are
totally free to use you just can't beat
it so policy users can promise
that you won't leave their website
feeling like a fool you could save 50 or
more by comparing life insurance quotes
and feel good knowing that it's if
something happens your loved ones will
be taken care of
go to policygenius.com to get started
policy genius when it comes to insurance
it's nice to get it right so we've been
told nearly every day
since january 6th that what transpired
at the capitol
that day was a deadly riot deadly riot
the media and elected democrats have
beaten to our heads
that five people died that day because
of the riots
sometimes the death toll is quoted as
seven the riots killed
seven people now we've known from the
beginning that this is at least
mostly bogus two of the seven were
suicides that occurred in the days and
weeks after the riot there was never the
slightest indication that the riot had
anything to do
with those suicides at all the media
drew a line connecting them in order to
shamelessly inflate the body count the
fact that they were doing this
that they felt the need to play this
grotesque and desperate game of connect
the dots
should have been the first clue that
something was wrong well scratch that
the first clue that the narrative was
false was simply the fact that
it was the narrative i mean you should
at this point question
literally anything that the left-wing
media tells you
i wouldn't believe that the sun rose
this morning without going out to check
myself
that that's that's the point we need to
be uh we need to have arrived at with
these people what about the other five
well
we were told that four of those deaths
were among the rioters
and one was capital police officer brian
siknik of the latter four
um or of the of the former four i should
say one was ashley babbitt an unarmed
woman shot and killed by an
unnamed capital police officer that's
one death that we could confirm from the
beginning because it was caught on video
we know that that happened the other
three were more vague
suspiciously vague the media wanted us
to know
that three individuals died during the
chaos or
after it or sometime in the vicinity of
it and they wanted us to draw from there
the conclusion that they were you know
not so subtly pointing us to they wanted
to give us a mental picture of a riot
where the participants were
beating and trampling each other to
death in fact it was reported that at
least one of the victims was trampled to
death
it wasn't until the first part of this
month
four months after the riot that the dc
medical examiner finally told us the
truth
or began to tell us the truth while
ashley babbitt's death was of course a
homicide committed again by a capital
police officer
the other three were not two died of
natural causes
a stroke or and a heart attack and uh
one was an accidental overdose
so already five of that original tally
of seven
had been revealed to be false the deadly
riot that claimed seven lives have been
reduced to potentially
two lives which leads us to officer
brian sicknick
now if you listen to the show you know
that i questioned the story about
officer signing from the very beginning
it was reported early on that officer
siknik was killed in the riot
murdered originally the media said that
um
he was beaten over the head by a fire
extinguisher and basically bludgeoned to
death
that gave way to a story that he was
sprayed by some foreign chemical
and and that's how he was killed i
didn't believe either of these stories
and my reasons were
one because i'm always going to be
suspicious when the media and the left
pretends to mourn a dead cop i mean
they'd never found a dead cop they cared
about until this one
that alone makes me question everything
they say about the case
his value to them was purely political
that that doesn't necessarily mean that
they're lying but it does mean that you
can't take them at their word
number two the story was far too vague
to be true
or to be entirely true initially it was
reported that that officer sicknick was
injured
while engaging with protesters injured
while engaging with protesters that's
what we were
the initial report was that that's how
it was phrased and then he later died
now the phrasing there was far too
calculated and careful
it's clearly meant to give us the
impression that protesters killed him
but it doesn't say that it doesn't even
say that
he was injured by protesters only that
he was injured while
engaging with protesters
none of this phrasing makes any sense if
he was really beat to death by crazed
rioters
if that's what happened they'd know it
and they'd say it
and also it would almost certainly be on
film if not the crime itself happening
then at least the aftermath we'd have
some
video of this an officer was beat to
death in the middle of a crowd
that would be if that hap that happened
to be very obvious
and you have to believe there'd be some
photo video somewhere yeah we never saw
any video
we were never given any additional
information nobody was ever arrested for
the crime
and this situation maintained for months
even as the media and the left
continued to say confidently as a matter
of fact that sickness was killed by
by protesters and then finally
yesterday well well over now four months
later
the medical examiner tells the truth
here's the report from embassy
washington again this came out
yesterday u.s capitol police officer
brian signing who died um
the day after he defended the capitol
during the january sixth quote
insurrection
suffered strokes and died of natural
causes
according to the dc's chief medical
examiner sicknick 42 collapsed hours
after the riot and died january 7th
in what officials consider a line of
duty death
federal federal authorities have been
clear that signic was assaulted with a
powerful chemical spray in his face
they said signic and other officers were
overpowered and potentially briefly
blinded
potentially briefly blinded notice the
phrasing there
by that spray while on the on the front
lines
dc's office of the chief medical
examiner said monday that sign's cause
of death was acute
brain stem and cerebellar infarcts
uh due to acute bacillar artery
thrombosis
probably mispronounced all of that but
the point is the manner of death was
natural not a homicide okay
natural causes not a homicide
now to be clear about this the medical
examiner along with officials in dc
elected democrats the national media
all of them almost certainly knew this
very early on
i mean there there were reports to this
effect
um in conservative media and
conservative
blogs a day later
are we supposed to believe that the
mainstream media didn't know
it would have been extremely clear that
officer picnic was not bludgeoned to
death
it didn't take them four months to
figure out that he died of a stroke he
was cremated three months ago
it's not as though they've been doing a
medical examination this whole time
he was cremated three months ago what
have they been doing in the last three
months
no they knew and they didn't tell us
this is not a simple matter of
misreporting
this is a matter of information being
withheld intentionally
and for reasons that we can speculate
about
where does this leave us it leaves us
with this protesters on january 6th
didn't kill seven people they didn't
kill
anyone they were killed
the only death caused by someone on the
scene that day
was that of ashley babbitt the rest was
lies and misinformation
and many people fell for it they fell
for it because they want to believe
that they can believe the most prominent
sources of information in this country
they want to believe that they can turn
on the tv and basically trust
what they're told they want to believe
that in this age of information the
information they receive is reliable
they don't want to believe that they're
being lied to all the time everywhere
and i can understand those desires but
they're not based in reality the fact is
that anytime you turn on the news or go
online
you are walking into a whirlwind of
propaganda
that's the fact and this shows it
so keep your head on straight bring a
healthy dose of skepticism with you
all the time and don't let them lead you
astray
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
yeah my question is what kind of [ __ ]
is going to waste their time
walking around an auto parts store if
they don't have to it might be a little
aggressive rock auto didn't tell me to
say one that was my own editorial
rockauto.com you know they're going to
say [ __ ] or not there's no reason to go
to an auto parts store if you don't have
to
waste all your time waste your money
you're not getting the kind of selection
you could get
you're spending more money than you have
to you're wasting more time than you
have to
no reason to do that you have access to
rockauto.com at your desk and in your
pocket rockauto.com
always offers the lowest prices possible
rather than changing prices
uh based on what they think they can get
out of you this is not you know whether
you're do it yourself or a professional
or somewhere in between
it's gonna be the same price for
everybody rockauto.com is a family
business they've been serving auto parts
customers online for 20 years go to
rockauto.com to shop for auto and body
parts from hundreds of manufacturers
best of all prices at rockauto.com are
always reliably low
and again they're the same for everybody
the rockawater.com catalog is unique
and remarkably easy to navigate you can
quickly see all the parts available
and make a decision amazing selection
reliably low prices go to rockauto.com
right now see all the parts available
for your car or truck and remember to
write walsh in there how did you hear
about us box
so they know that we sent you well
you may be able to tell me losing my
voice the last couple days
and um here's the thing i'm a
responsible i'm a responsible adult
and i need my voice to do my job you
know so it's really a really important
tool
for for me anyway and um
so as a responsible person i said like
last night i need to make sure that i
give my voice a rest
um you know and then i just take it easy
and so i spent the night um smoking
cigars and
drinking whiskey so that was that was my
responsible way of dealing with it
one of those times when the nighttime
version of yourself
um writes a check that your morning self
has to cash in
well a lot you know maybe in your 20s
you have a lot of moments like that
one such moment for me um okay so i have
to share this with you this is a tweet
from
yamiche alcindor who's a pbs reporter
a couple here we're gonna go now as
we're waiting for the verdict in the uh
derek shoving case um and
the media now is left to just
analyze and speculate and everything so
we've gotten a lot of legal
analysis from the media and maybe i
should stop short of calling it
shockingly bad
given everything about the media that we
just covered in the opening there
but i mean this is it is sort of
shockingly bad so here's yamiche
alcindor again pbs reporter
she tweeted this this is her analysis
shovin's lawyer said it flies in the
face of common sense to say that floyd's
death was not caused at least in part by
his underlying conditions of drug use
this argument is in direct contradiction
to the prosecution's case
which says believe your eyes chauvin's
knee killed floyd
in direct contradiction oh the
so the the defense is making a case
that's in
this is in direct contradiction to what
the prosecution is saying
i mean you gotta admit it's pretty rude
of the defense
the prosecution they spend all their
time
making their case they build their case
they bring in their witnesses
they have whatever evidence in this case
they didn't have a lot of evidence but
whatever they have they bring
um it's all that effort that they put in
and uh yamiche alcindor is kind of upset
that the defense would get up there and
have a different
version of events
after all this effort
pretty i don't know i agree with her
actually
pretty could we could just say pretty
tacky
pretty tacky for the for the defense to
get up there
and have an opposite version of events
you know the prosecution should have
just objected and said no hang on a
second that's not what we said
this is the opposite of what we said
this is something isn't right here
meanwhile if you thought that was bad
this is way worse meanwhile laura coates
cnn's senior legal analyst has this
here's what she says um defense begins
the closing by defining reasonable doubt
not with why derek chovin is innocent
think about that
hashtag derek shove and trial hashtag
george floyd
think about that the defense is
relying on reasonable doubt
that's unheard of that's almost as
unheard of as the defense having a
different version of events than the
prosecution
only reasonable doubt and they're not
they're not saying innocent
yeah that's like every murder trial ever
in america anyway
that's that's that is the defense's
whole job is to
um so reasonable doubt in the jury
and it would be it would be uh
misconduct
on the part of that of of chauvin's
lawyers
if chopin's lawyers got up there in the
closing and said we want you to believe
that derek chovin is completely innocent
and is an innocent great guy
that's what we want you to believe no
you're raising the bar farther than you
need to
why would you do that
no the way it's set up is that the bar
is supposed to be lower than that
you don't you don't have to believe that
derek chovin is innocent you don't have
to believe that he's innocent
you certainly don't have to like him as
a person
but but yeah you don't have to believe
he's innocent
you just have to think that there there
could be a reasonable chance
that he may be innocent and if you think
there's a reasonable chance
that he may be innocent then you can't
convict
that's what the defense is trying to get
across
that and and that's and that's as far as
you can go anyway because that's that's
what this trial really comes down to
right it's it there's
there's no way the defense can prove
can categorically absolutely prove
that um george floyd died purely of a
drug overdose
and not because of the neonac they can't
absolutely prove that
but they don't need to the prosecution
needs to
absolutely prove that um
even though he had a fatal dose of
fentanyl in his system that's not what
killed him
that's what they have to prove
and and the jury has to decide if they
did prove it
having followed the trial i i don't see
how they did
meanwhile um the judge in the shelving
case had some words about maxine waters
we'll play this for you first he uh you
know we know maxine waters flew
from dc to minneapolis to get the crowd
riled up
and to intimidate and tamper with the
jury
um uh chauvin's defense
raises an objection actually tried to
move for a mistrial saying that
you know this is this is intimidating
the jury this is a jury tampering
and the judge said there's not gonna be
mistrial he did concede though that um
that that maxine waters may have given a
pretense to appeal and overturn the
whole child
for the defense if they want and then
the judge said this let's listen
this goes back to what i've been saying
from the beginning i wish elected
officials would stop
talking about this case especially in a
manner that is disrespectful
to the rule of law and to the judicial
branch in our function
think if they want to give their
opinions they should do so
in a respectful and in a manner that is
consistent with their oath to the
constitution
to respect the co-equal branch of
government
their failure to do so i think is
abhorrent but i don't think it is
prejudices
with additional uh material that would
prejudice history they have been told
not to watch the news
i trust they are following those
instructions and that there is not
in any way uh a prejudice to the event
beyond the articles that we're talking
specifically about the facts of this
case
a congresswoman's opinion really doesn't
matter a whole lot anyway
so motion for mistrial is denied okay a
congresswoman's opinion doesn't matter a
whole lot well it doesn't matter in
terms of
of changing the reality um it and
i think what he means to say is it
shouldn't matter
if you're on the jury it shouldn't
matter to you what this crazy wacky
um scumbag politician has to say
shouldn't matter but that's a far cry
from saying that it doesn't
and so we're just we're just hoping i
don't see why this prejudiced the jury
you know that we told them not to watch
the news
so this all in order for this to really
be a fair trial
we we have to hope and assume
that the jury first of all went in
without any preconceived
biases um that they're not going to make
a decision based on emotion but based on
facts
um that they're not going to be
intimidated
even before maxine waters that i could
be intimidated by
you know thoughts that their lives could
be ruined they could be docs they could
be hunted down if they if they
find a chauvin not guilty
they're not going to watch any news
throughout the trial
and uh and also now that there's
politicians there trying to rile the
the the rioters up they're not going to
be affected by that
i mean we are expecting a lot of this
jury
you you may say expecting an
unreasonable
amount from this jury
almost almost we're expecting this point
to exercise
superhuman restraint and courage
that's really the only way that this
that this ends up being a fair trial is
if
these jurors have super human restraint
and courage
restraint to not watch the news at all
even though nothing's done to prevent
them from doing it
and courage to um to look at
the situation and say yeah you know what
if i find him not guilty my life could
be over
but i'm gonna do the right thing
it's just not it's it's almost certainly
not gonna happen
if there was ever time for a mistrial
this would be it
and if you have the trial again you
don't have it in minneapolis
and you sequester the jury
and if any politicians pull that stun
again it's another mistrial
i mean the whole the idea the claim that
what maxine waters did was anything but
jury intimidation
and tampering what else would it be
what other motivation could you have
if you're maxine waters and you're
leaving dc to go to minneapolis
um before the jury has even begun
deliberating
demanding that they come to a certain
conclusion
and threatening confrontation if they
don't
if that's not jury tampering and
intimidation what it what qualifies if
that doesn't
and what reason so if if her if her goal
was not to intimidate the jury then what
was it
what was she hoping to do
i think we all know totally absurd
so this this should be a mistrial it
should have been mistrial from the very
beginning
um but it's not and so
at this point i will be floored
if they come back with a not guilty
verdict not because he doesn't you know
because the not guilty verdict would be
incorrect i think that is the correct
verdict
but just as i said to get 12 people
together and for them all to have that
superhuman restrained courage
very unlikely very unlikely okay number
two i've been wanting to play this story
uh talk about the story for
for like a week and i keep putting it
off because other things come first but
but you know i'm part of the problem in
doing this because this is really a huge
story
um and here's a report from the today
show about the imminent alien invasion
and let's watch that in night vision
video from a navy destroyer
a mysterious flying triangle above the
deck of the ship
the pentagon confirming the images
obtained by documentary filmmaker jeremy
corbil
were taken by navy personnel expected to
be a part of a report on
unidentified aerial phenomenon to be
presented to congress this summer
already online some skeptics say the
images are caused by cameras trying to
focus
but some of the objects go beyond just
flying in the sky
one shows a spherical object dipping
into the ocean similar to an incident in
puerto rico where an object was tracked
buzzing an airport
then flying into the water popping back
out before appearing to split into two
and disappearing over the last several
weeks some of the nation's top former
intelligence officials have been raising
eyebrows
former cia director r james woolsey said
he knew of a case
where a plane was paused in midair a
friend of mine
was able to have his aircraft
stop at 40 000 feet or so
and not continue
operating as a normal uh aircraft
yeah how is this how is this not like
the only thing we're talking about
oh just uh the pentagon confirming
sites by pilots of of aircraft doing
things that are physically impossible
splitting into dipping into the ocean
and coming back out
defying the laws of physics well that's
it
no big deal i mean they're
right there are really only two
explanations
and one is that
there's some other foreign power in
in our world on earth
that has technological abilities that
that
go way way beyond anything that we can
even conceive of
you know there's a there's a another
country on earth
that has technology so advanced
that when we see it we have to entertain
the possibility that may be from another
planet
like there's an another country with
literally other worldly technology
that's one possibility right and the
other possibility is
it's not from this world i'm not exactly
sure what the third
potential possibility would be
you know i if it wasn't if this wasn't
being confirmed by the pentagon and if
it wasn't for the source these are navy
pilots military people
people know what they're looking at it
wasn't for that you could say ah it
might be fake it might be
camera tricks it might be a bug on the
lens you know weather balloon
weird weather pattern you could you
could speculate about all that but i
think those possibilities are really
are really ruled out
so i think we know this this is some
kind of
flying technology and um
either it's from this planet or it's not
but either way
that's a huge deal
and if there is you know if this is from
china
let's say or russia or something um
why haven't they just taken over the
whole world
if they can do that
they have aircraft that can split into
dip into the ocean
go at supersonic speeds and then stop
and turn around go the other way
why haven't they taken over the whole
world yet if that's the case
maybe they will and here we are
you know and even me i'm part of the
problem i just said i've had
i've been wanting to talk about this but
i put it off
so that i could play tick-tock videos of
of fat women dancing
you know i'm so much a part of this
problem i'm ashamed i should be canceled
for that
in fact we have another tick tock video
today i think that we're going to play
fat women dancing
um and that is important don't get me
wrong
we got to know what the fat women are
doing on tick tock but at the same time
you know
potentially there's there are alien
there's an
alien super civilization out there
preparing to take over the planet
and we're all like yeah
whatever okay um
moving on moving on from that um this is
from the daily wire it says
after years of pro-life criticism plant
paranoid's president and chief executive
officer alex mcgill johnson
now says the abortion provider is
reckoning with the legacy of its founder
margaret sanger and they're looking to
cancel
the early abortion and birth control
advocate over her connections to
white supremacist groups and eugenics
the abortion provider has largely
avoided evidence that sanger founded her
quote family planning crusade
um because sanger a pioneer of the
eugenics movement of the early 20th
century felt it was necessary to prevent
the tainted and less desirable from
reproducing
as she noted in various publications um
now though in a more woke era sanger is
uh problematic and planned parenthood
now hopes to distance itself from its
own founding principles in order to
erase its history as a racist and
ableist institution
um and so they're they're sort of
let's try to move on to what the um
[Music]
what planned parenthood is now saying
about this
although johnson stopped short of
acknowledging the racial focus of much
as saying of sanger's writing
she says quote we can't simply call her
racist scrub her from our history and
move on
she does acknowledge that sanger spoke
to the ku klux klan and that saenger
cheered a supreme court decision
allowing states to sterilize people
deemed unfit
without their consent and sometimes
without their knowledge
instead johnson said sanger's primary
sin was focusing on white womanhood
which runs afoul of today's
intersectional feminism
she says quote we don't know what was in
sanger's heart and we don't need to
we don't need to in order to condemn her
her harmful choices
what we have is a history of focusing on
white womanhood relentlessly
whether our founder was a racist is not
a simple yes or no question
our reckoning is understanding her full
legacy and its impact
our reckoning is the work that comes
next okay
of course they get no credit for first
of all
pro-lifers have been pointing this out
about margaret sanger
so it's not like the planned parenthood
could claim oh we never noticed
we never noticed what our founders said
about we never noticed that she was an
uh you know an out-and-out eugenicist
they can't claim that uh it wouldn't be
credible under any circumstance but
especially when you had pro-lifers
for decades that have been saying this
and planned parenthood either ignored it
or they or they would deny it and say
it's not true you're misinterpreting
you're
lying about what she said they did fact
checks and everything
um or they would focus on like there's
this is one of the this is a tactic
especially of left-wing fact-checkers
there's a an alleged photo out there of
margaret
speaking to a ku klux klan rally group
um and the photo is not real the photo
was doctored by somebody
so that's one of those things where the
fact checkers they say
there's a claim that that there's a
photo of margaret sanger
speaking to uh kkk rally that's fact
check
false well yes it's it's false in that
there was
the photo is not real but she did
actually do that
so you're focusing on on the the fact
that a photo is made up
fine but she did do that she did go and
speak to the kkk
we know that
and we have certainly canceled
historical figures for far
less than that
but no matter what they do they don't
deserve credit for it um this is only a
matter of self-preservation it's all
politics obviously
but also there's they can't really
fully confront the legacy of margaret
sanger
because they are the legacy of margaret
sanger
abortion has always been
eugenic in nature
it's about getting rid of the unwanted
unwanted babies or the unwanted
quote-unquote fetus that's that's what
it has always been
so if they were really going to reckon
with the legacy of margaret sanger and
condemn it
distance themselves from it that would
necessitate that they stop
aborting the unwanted
they would have to reject the idea that
a human being
deserves to be killed because they're
unwanted
that is a eugenic idea margaret sanger's
idea
as long as they keep doing it so they
can say all they want oh yeah margaret's
saying or we you know we don't want
anything to do with her anymore
while they go on killing 300 000
unwanted children every year talk about
hollow words
all right let's play this george george
w bush was interviewed on cbs about his
great compassion the media has recently
discovered a newfound love
of bush this began a few years ago
and that's what led to this you ran as a
compassionate conservative i did
do you believe there are compassionate
conservatives today absolutely i'm one
and i think there are a lot uh the
problem is
uh with an angry society
it it's hard to punch through with
compassion
is it an angry society or is it a
certain leaders and people who've stoked
that anger and fear
i think there's a that's an interesting
question uh i'm a big leadership
guy and and so therefore i i think maybe
maybe the latter part of your question
is true that people stoke
anger in order to advance their
apolitical agenda
uh i do believe there is a more uh well
my dad spoke of a kinder and gentler
uh and he truly believed it and i
believed in
uh unifier not divider and and
they just can't be empty slogans you
have to believe it in order to be
credible
uh i think uh
that yes it's gonna require leadership
to help heal heal wounds
this is uh so hard to watch
you've got cbs reporters
interviewing george w bush about his
compassion you're such a compassionate
guy
that's not just just maybe for younger
people
who don't remember the bush ears that
much i just tell you
that is not what they were saying about
george w bush at the time
they were calling him a war criminal
saying he was
sound familiar he's worse than hitler
all that kind of stuff
i mean they hated him uh
again maybe if you're younger you know
you might not remember this or realize
it but
i i could tell you that donald trump is
not the first republican president the
media hated
they've hated them all uh and george
bush in particular
but now they they trot him out because
they find him useful
when they can talk about compassion
and as i've said many times about this
about compassion i believe in compassion
compassion is a is a
central aspect to living a moral life
and being a moral person
but what does compassion mean
it's not compassion is not to simply
sit back and not interfere while your
whole civilization crumbles around you
compassion is not um refraining from
speaking out when you see evil
that's not that's the opposite of
compassion
you're you're leaving people to wallow
in misery
and death that's not compassion
compassion co-passion co-suffering
it means when you're you are sharing in
the suffering of another to the extent
that you can
that's what compassion means
and so i think for conservatives it it
it means now
you know getting down into the trenches
culturally
and and fighting this fight
they're suffering that comes from that
there's hardship that comes from that
but you're doing it because you're
fighting for truth and what is what is
right and moral and just
that's compassionate and if you
use harsh language sometimes while you
do it um if you raise your voice a
little bit that doesn't make it any less
compassionate
especially if what's making you angry is
your passion for truth
and goodness and virtue
so that's what real conservative
compassion should look like
okay finally it's time for me again to
force you to watch a tick tock video
i do this because it's important it's
important for you to know what's
happening on tick tock why is that
important
just because stop asking questions
you're gonna watch this
and like it damn it here it
a is even though in comments you're like
cap
time you spend with me you'll be time
well spent and if i get on top you know
i'm leaving a dent
know you want a party without fat buy my
diamonds give me name brand
chips time to spend with me
[Music]
two minutes with me and you'll be
calling me daddy might not pass the
presidential fitness test but notify
your next can i'll put you to rest
whiny little dude says i'm concerned for
your health and think about my battles
while they're touching themselves
they comment i legitimately thought this
was john candy then whisper my name
as they start to get randy
on second thought it probably there was
no reason to play that um
but i did and so you've seen it
i don't know if there's any commentary
necessary
after witnessing that aside from the
fact that um
you know just to remind everyone mental
illness is an epidemic in this country
so is obesity and so is tick tock and
sometimes those
things all come together in that way and
we all we all
suffer because of it so there you go all
right let's go to reading the youtube
comments this is from the masked man who
says i don't know how matt did it but
his voice sounds even manlier during
this episode
unamused caveman says matt's voice made
my beard grow a beard
emil says matt's voice hurt my throat
okay i hope you guys all got did you get
that your system yeah a lot i got all
the
the voice jokes you'll have a few more
days to do that
hope you got out of your system yes my
voice sounds jacked up that's true
thank you for establishing that you big
bullies i hope my voice still sounds
like this on friday when i wear the
polka dot shirt
that's what that's what you deserve um
another one says hey matt i watched the
daniel shaver shooting a couple of times
did you not notice right before the
officer shot daniel's right hand
moved from the floor and towards his
back watch it again
yeah i um i'm a
yes i that is the justification they
gave for shooting him
is that a good justification for
shooting him no why did he why did he
move his hand
because his pants were falling down it's
what it seems to me and he was just
trying to pull his pants up it's like a
reflexive thing that you do
to try to maintain your dignity um
in whatever way you can when you when
there's a man pointing a gun at you and
forcing you to crawl on the ground
towards him
but it was clear to that point you know
that's why i
that's not an excuse for shooting him
for a number of reasons
first of all this daniel shaver
to that point had shown that he is
desperate to comply with them he was
trying
everything he could to comply with
everything they said
his compliance was was he was
broadcasting that
to the point where he was crawling on
his hands and knees towards them
a move which by the way i have no i'm no
law enforcement expert
i've never seen that before
i've talked to a lot of law enforcement
people they've said they've never been
in a situation where they've told
someone to crawl towards them
and if there could ever be a situation
where you would ask someone to do that
or
tell them to do it um i don't know why
that would be the situation like why
can't he
he's on you told him to get down on the
ground put his hands behind his back
okay just go go up and cuff him why do
you even crawl to you doesn't make any
sense
um so i don't buy it for that reason
also it's just it was cl you know
yes you could never know for sure
someone could be hiding a gun but the
chances
that that he was hiding a gun i think
were very very low
and um when he's crawling towards you
yeah i mean even if
like on the on the on the off chance on
the very very
vanishingly small chance that he's
actually reaching for a gun
um you would have plenty of time to
shoot him dead before he could draw it
up and shoot you
there were three armed officers in a
hallway
pointing their guns at him
he's on his hands and knees crawling
now i know it can all happen pretty
quickly but on the off chance
on like the one percent chance that he
that he was reaching for a gun there
i think you'd you'd have at least a
moment to fire your
your guns uh before he could draw all
the way up from the crawling position
and start firing at you
and that's why we say you know the
i think most unjust police shootings
and most police shootings are not unjust
but the ones that are unjust it's
usually
not racism or homicidal mania that
drives it
it's it's self-preservation that drives
it
that's also what what drives most of the
just police shootings
but self-preservation can can go too far
sometimes for a police officer
i mean we shouldn't expect them to take
unreasonable risks and put their lives
on the line unreasonably
but yeah you do have to take some risk
even a small amount of risk
because if we say that police officers
shouldn't have to take any risk at all
well then they're just going to kill
everybody right
so that clearly is not the case so i
guess my point is
would if if they had refrained from
shooting him and he didn't have a gun he
was unarmed
so if they refrain from shooting him
they would have been fine
but if they'd refrain from pulling the
trigger in that instant
what are the chances that they would
have end up dead ended up dead
you know in that scenario i think very
very very very very very small
um another way of putting it that's a
chance that i think we should
require them to take instead of just
killing a guy
just in case right
we don't want any just in case killings
we want we want we want the police to
shoot when when there's no other choice
and they have to protect their own lives
protect protect the public
which again most police shootings that's
that's what it is
they do it because there's no other
choice
um okay let's see
one other uh okay here's one other thing
eric gomez says day seven of me asking
if matt can read my comment
to tell me where he got that sloth
you're talking about the sloth on my
leftist tears tumbler here thank you for
noticing very few people notice the
sloth but he's my my dear friend here
and you can go to my instagram to to see
how i received that sloth and many other
gifts in this room so a little instagram
plug for you
now a quick word from our very good
friends at constitutioncoach.com
you know we als we all as conservatives
what do we say we love the constitution
we love our second amendment rights in
particular
but how many of us know enough about the
constitution and are ready to defend it
how many of us
have the ability to exercise our second
women rights if we really need to
my friends over at constitutioncouch.com
they've got a lot of great programs that
are going to solve that problem and
they're going to equip
citizens to defend liberty by studying
and living out the constitution
i've experienced their constitutional
defense course you can experience it too
well their their their classes on april
25th it's filling up fast
you get an amazing combination of
intellectual ammunition and live classes
with rick green america's constitution
coach and then you also get the physical
training at the premier firearms
training facility in the nation
get all this in the same course you have
to join hundreds of other patriots from
across the nation for a time of learning
training and fellowship with like-minded
people uh it doesn't matter where you
are
on the you know where your skills are
they're going to take you to a whole new
skill level they're going to make you a
lot more confident
handling firearms that's what they did
for me i mean i was i was way on on one
side of the skill level not the side
that i wanted to be on
and felt so much better after doing this
course and you will too
don't just get a gun learn to carry with
confidence learn how to defend yourself
and your family go to
constitutioncoach.com rick in the
constitution coach team
have another class on april 25th but it
will fill up fast so visit
constitutioncoach.com today
and uh find out about how you can be a
part of this one-of-a-kind training
constitutioncoach.com
you know it's almost time for another
episode of candace this week's special
guest is dana white president of ufc of
course
uh which is the large largest mma
organization in the world
and he's always got a lot of really
interesting things so you don't want to
miss this the show streams
on friday at 9 p.m uh eastern 8 p.m
central
on dailywire.com if you if you don't
have a membership yet you can go
use code canvas to get 25 off and also
if you don't know about this yet you can
also get the podcast of candace which is
available on apple or spotify or
wherever you get your podcast and if you
go there make sure to leave a five star
review
if you like what you hear now let's get
to our daily cancellation
today for our daily cancellation we turn
again to the slippery slope
the thing that we're all sliding down
though we never reach the end of our
plummet
we hurdle endlessly into the abyss never
to stop
our misery compounding by the moment but
never ending
never culminating in anything except
more insanity and more despair
but the good news is that it gives me
plenty of chances to say i told you so
that's the one good thing as we're all
hurtling down
into hell i can say hey guys told you so
here's another chance from the new york
post um it says consensual incest
advocates
are rooting for an anonymous new york
parent who wants to marry their own
adult child
australian richard morris who is pushing
to change incest laws in about 50 60
countries
said he supports the legal push in
manhattan federal court that such
behavior between consenting adults
should not be criminalized he and other
advocates have launched about 130
petitions mostly on change.org
seeking to change incest laws around the
world most have received little support
we haven't moved any mountains yet he
told the post morris was inspired to
fight for those in consenting in sexual
relationships
he said after learning about a scottish
case in which a long-separated father
and daughter were reunited
started an affair and were then
criminally convicted
okay after you've finished vomiting all
over yourself
you should stop and consider this
according to the logic of the day
how can we condemn the father and
daughter couple
just mentioned does the prevailing
philosophy in our culture provide us a
basis to reject
the legitimacy of their viscerally
repulsive and disordered union
well richard morris doesn't think so
more from the post he says fighting for
true marriage equality is the right
thing to do isn't it morris said
it seems to be as unjust as the law that
used to imprison gay people
and the law that used to stop people
different races marrying he added
keith pullman who runs the blog full
marriage equality
also cheered on the new york lawsuit he
said quote it is absurd to say that an
adult can't consent to marry their
parent
the same adult can be sent to war take
on six figures of debt
uh operate heavy machinery be sentenced
to death by a federal court and consent
to sex with five strangers and marriage
with one of them
but can't consent to marry someone they
love he told the post in some of these
cases the genetic parent didn't raise
them and they met for the first time two
years ago
allegations of grooming are laughable
attempts to deny someone their right
even though it will have no impact on
the person objecting
all right now this article was not meant
it was not met with wide acclaim most
people seem to be
reacting with disgust and anger not just
at the incest advocates but at the post
for giving them a platform to make their
case
but what actually is the argument
against this
why can't father marry his adult
daughter we really think about it
it's not a rhetorical question ask
yourself why these cases of ancestral
incestuous relationships are wrong you
might say that the father can't marry
his daughter because even if she's an
adult
he's clearly been grooming her okay well
that might be a good enough answer in
some cases but the case in question
involves a father who was separated from
his daughter
and then reunited when they were both
adults assuming there was no grooming
and that they linked up again and
immediately struck up a sexual
relationship with each other
again with full consent why is that
wrong
why shouldn't we you know why shouldn't
they be allowed
to marry why should we not only allow
them to marry
but celebrate their union recognize it
as holy valid and good and beautiful
why shouldn't we this question
represents a real problem i think for a
lot of people in our culture
most people don't want to think of
themselves as incest advocates
they're repulsed by the idea they want
to condemn it
but when they think about it honestly
they realize that they don't have any
logical basis to condemn it
they don't have the language to explain
why they oppose it
they know they do but they can't say why
that is because as i've often observed
we have reduced sexual morality down to
a matter of mere consent
whereas consent used to be but one
requirement in order for a sexual act to
be considered more
moral and legitimate and good now it's
the only requirement
thankfully for the left this is this one
remaining thread consent
is enough to rule out things like
bestiality you know
they can always say that bestiality is
wrong because an animal can't consent
though even there it should disturb you
if the only reason
you can think to reject sexual
relationships between men
and goats is that men can't obtain
consent from goats
i mean that should be really the least
of your worries when it comes to man on
goat sex
you should have a whole bunch of reasons
why you're against it before you even
get to consent
but be that resume consent does the
trick here basically
it's even enough to rule out many cases
of incest where one or both people are
minors or where again one was groomed as
a minor
but then you run into cases like the one
described by the post
and their consent is not enough you're
faced with a choice
either come out and say that actually
there's nothing wrong with an adult
father
marrying his adult daughter and look at
yourself in the mirror when you say it
face yourself as an advocate for
father-daughter coupling
or admit that there's more to sexual
morality than consent
and there's more to marriage than simply
two people loving each other
those are your only two options
now i would say that the reason incest
is wrong has in many instances
nothing to do with consent it's also not
a matter of practicality or medical
complications
the problem isn't simply that incestuous
couples may have deformed children
if you make that your whole case well
then what about incestuous couples that
take
whatever steps necessary to ensure that
they don't conceive kids
no the reason this is wrong is because
it's intrinsically disordered
it is a severe and grotesque perversion
and subversion of
the familial relationship it is outside
of the proper order of things
that's not what families are supposed to
do with each other
the real significance of the birth
defect issue is that even if the
father-daughter couple avoids having
kids
the fact that their relationship carries
with it an inherent and significant risk
of creating birth defects
is but one sign among many that the
relationship is not what nature intends
or as i would put it not what god
intends
see in order to condemn this you have to
introduce concepts like
the natural order and human dignity
incest is an attack on both of those
things without those concepts though
you're defenseless
you can't very well defend the natural
order and human dignity
if you don't acknowledge their existence
and importance but if you do acknowledge
them
even if only to give you ammo to take
down the pro-incest talking points
well then you've introduced concepts
that have reverberating effects
and must now reshape your whole view of
sexual morality if you're intellectually
honest
now you have to reevaluate all sexual
acts and lifestyles and ask yourself
whether those are within the natural
order whether those are consistent with
human dignity
that's what the kids would call a red
pill moment
most people refuse to take it refuse to
think seriously about these issues
refuse to investigate their own
inconsistencies
refuse to ask themselves whether their
position on one topic is consistent with
their position on others
most people refuse that and so those
people
are canceled the incest advocates are
cancelled too of course but only because
i have the moral framework to cancel
them
many people on the left don't have that
moral framework and for that reason
they too are also canceled a lot of
people cancel today
always my favorite cancellations when i
can do that and we'll leave it there for
today
talk to you tomorrow have a great day
godspeed
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadosky
the show is edited by sasha tulmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by nika geneva and
our production coordinator is mckenna
waters
the matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 21.
today on the ben shapiro show as the
chauvin jury begins its deliberations
the media ratchet up
the racial tension and maxine waters
pushes violence in the street
as democrats and the media defend her as
today on the bench bureau show give it a
listen